you break the rules
can't wait to see that squiddy
i do it and i become the enemy that's
right
it's true
that doesn't seem fair it's not fair
it's not fair at all who raises some
good points doesn't seem fair
welcome back to new rock stars a new
trailer for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness is giving us fresh
looks at elizabeth olsen as wanda
maximoff the scarlet witch this week
marked one year since the finale of juan
division showed wanda ascend into that
nexus role and now with rumors that
elizabeth olsen might be extending her
seven year contract with marvel studios
into a dark new future what will that
dark future darkhold
welcome back to inside marvel new
rockstars weekly marvel reaction show
i'm eric voss with me is mt
mt do you remember where you were this
time a year ago uh with one division
coming to an end answering all of our
questions rough bonering some of us i
cannot believe it has been a year like
literally i just remember just being
in my bedroom just like
jaw just dropped just being like i can't
believe well first of all jaw dropped
because of the ralph boner thing because
i was like are you serious but second of
all just like that whole ride that we
were just went on just like it was just
was unlike anything that we ever
experienced at mcu ever so like i can't
believe it's already been a year i can't
believe it's been a year it it and it
changed everything like i i uh i loved
that whole journey start to finish uh
just those first couple episodes feeling
like we're watching the twilight zone
like what is this exactly and then week
after week rules being rewritten
mysteries being opened up and all of us
all of us at the you know as kovan
had just shut down everything finally we
had something to bring us all together
again to geek out together week after
week it was such a fun
ride and you know yeah obviously some of
my theories were
totally disproven by the end of that
series but
now with multiverse of mad it just seems
like i wasn't that crazy to be bringing
up names like kathan and bringing up the
darkhold and agatha harkness's
witchcraft origins because it's it's now
being proven to be correct it looks like
by multiverse of madness in an insane
way bro like that ending of the trailer
without the multiple hands and like
strange being possessed like there has
to be some type of darker forces at play
so like for sure i would definitely feel
like you're you're you weren't
unreasonable there yeah i almost want to
like go back and re-watch every episode
of wanda vision and do like another
breakdown just ignoring all the stuff
that was red herrings uh but just kind
of to look back on it nostalgically and
say remember when we thought this and
now as we're looking down the barrel at
multiverse of madness it actually looks
like that might still be something
because in the months since then it we
honestly felt like crazy people and now
we feel crazy again
with multiverse of madness and it's just
so exciting now to look ahead at uh
juana max moff's future in the mcu
that's what we're going to talk about
this episode specifically her future
beyond multiverse of madness if these
rumors are true that olson is extending
her contract with marvel what titles
should we see her in next and what major
crossover events do we think she may be
the the anchor point of will we see her
in her own solo series possibly
it's not marvel related but we have some
exciting announcements with our merch
batman is out our friends at epic hero
shop have a new latest obsession limited
edition shirt for the batman gotham noir
it's an incredible looking shirt with a
really cool artful design it's not gonna
be around for long though so you gotta
go jump on this quickly they're no way
home and shung cheese shirts sold out
really fast so you really gotta grab one
of these before it's sold out but mt
this week inside marvel what are we
talking about well our first question of
the day is eric uh wanda
or
will wanda appear next like where will
wanda appear next yeah wanna maximoff is
marvel's greatest turnaround success of
phase four i'm gonna say it right now uh
she went from being one of the most
poorly defined and really underutilized
avengers in phase three she was really
back benched in age of ultron civil war
infinity war and end game to now being
the face of marvel's deep character
explorations on disney plus and now the
villain and or anti-hero many of us are
most excited to see multiverse of
madness i've made the argument that
multiverse of madness may be equally a
doctor strange in his variants movie as
it is a scarlet witch in her mutants
movie
along with tom hiddleston as loki olson
is undoubtedly kevin feige's mvp talent
from that first year of disney plus
titles and since hiddleston's future is
certainly set with future seasons of
loki it's really a foregone conclusion
that feige must be eager to renew
olson's contract and use her as much as
possible in marvel's future titles with
one division multiverse of madness we
are now seeing wanda's true rebirth as a
character this is the start of something
and assuming marvel studios sees her
that way too let's look at the titles
ahead on the mcu calendar that would be
the best fits for her return and we'll
start with the titles that are confirmed
for the calendar um agatha house of
harkness title we'll talk about really
the most natural fit for olson's return
one of vision showrunner jack schaefer
is returning and she's referring to it
really as a second season of one
division and recently catherine hahn
gave us an update telling entertainment
weekly that house of hardness is still
in development but what she's seen so
far
is quote exactly what i would have hoped
and dripped so yeah that's good tell us
anything other than get excited just a
reminder of where uh the harkness was
left in this universe still under
scarlet witch trance right in the city
of west view new jersey but we did not
see agatha after
the illusion dropped you know like the
the hex faded uh and the citizens of
west view were now glaring at wanda
maximoff uh broken from that trance but
we didn't see agatha among them i have
to assume that for the world's
protection wanda would have kept that
trance in place but what do you think mt
are we gonna open with house of harkness
with agatha being a brainwashed and
gasoline in a kind of sitcom reality the
way wanda began one division we're gonna
have like another episode another weird
sitcom
episode with uh with agatha i think that
house of harkness like very well could
start off with this scenario where she's
just her mind is completely wiped and
agatha thinks that she is this
completely different person until
something or someone or someone
reawakens her into her agatha persona
but like i always had this really fun
idea of house of harkness being like um
just
kind of like this like weird universe
taking place within agatha's mind as
she's working through like the spell
breaking through wanda spell like you
like she's like meeting every single
witch or like being that she's like
sucked over the courses of centuries
so like this is the house of agatha
harkness's mind and like in all the
souls that she's tortured over the years
it's like i think that'd be really fun
and for wanda to be one of those souls
to be like ah you tortured me too so
like here's me tortured your back and
sort of like i think it'd be really fun
there but yeah i think one yeah
returning in house of harkness would be
the best like the most rational thing
it'd be kind of weird if she didn't at
that point like come on like why
wouldn't wanda just make a cameo there
right absolutely i mean this is like a
perfect place for rwanda max moff to
come back and and continue to haunt uh
catherine hahn maybe uh turn the table
on her right the way that uh agatha was
kind of this weird nosy neighbor who uh
would drop these weird lines and kind of
screw with her and at some point show up
in a director's chair imagine wanda
being in that director's chair of this
show
now you would lose some of that mystery
you'd lose a lot of that mystery to be
honest right that's that was the driving
force of one division's earlier episodes
is we knew that there was some kind of
conspiracy at work we just didn't know
who was really behind it and that
mystery kept us kept us going week after
week so we need something else to kind
of drive that mystery that mystery could
just be something like how is agatha
gonna break out of this uh or maybe we
like flash forward at the beginning of
this season to where agatha is now back
in control of the dark hole doing
something horrible like torturing
someone or or plotting something
horrible for blade or from moon night or
something like that because like if it
is a second season of one division if
you're pitching this to disney plus if
you're pitching this to a network right
like you want to pitch it it's going to
have the same kind of momentum that one
division season one did right which was
like episode after episode it's like a
different sitcom homage like we had uh
you know and i love lucy episode you
know uh we had a bewitched episode we
had a brady bunch episode so like i'd
i'd be dying to see them continue that
see and i think
catherine hans perfectly suited if they
don't want to do sitcoms they could do
something like
charmed or buffy the vampire slayer
parodies you know like things that are
kind of more action comedies like you
could do other tv shows uh or you could
do
other kind of genres that aren't like
sitcoms like america i really love that
idea of like paying obagis like
different types of witch media it's like
you could do charm and then you could do
like something more serious really like
i think you just go
around that i think there's a lot of
value there that's a really good idea i
love that you could do like true blood
and that kind of thing like other kind
of supernatural
um recent stuff that that people are
digging so i think yeah we definitely
need to see an agatha wanda rematch at
some point on this series and uh i think
absolutely we're gonna need to see
elizabeth olsen return there but let's
talk about some of the other horror
titles that we know are on the calendar
we have moon night coming up next at the
end of this month right um moon knight
seems to be exploring a different corner
of the supernatural side of the mcu do
you think elizabeth olsen could show up
as a cameo or at least get reference
that this scarlet witch
could be someone who shows up in uh in
some text or or in a monologue by konchu
or something like that i definitely feel
like there's a definite chance that
scarlet witch could show up in moon
knight because like at some point in the
moonlight trailer arthur harrow mentions
that moon knight has chaos in his mind
and i think that he's referring to chaos
energy and chaos magic so like that i
feel like that could be a root to like
you know us learning that moon knight
and like the the conscious magic and
conscious power has some type of chaos
magic connection there and that you know
wanda maximov could be you know maybe
like wanting moon knight's power for
herself like so she can help bring her
children back so like i think there's a
lot of opportunity there for wanda to to
be a part of moon knight but what do you
think you know there um there was this
detail that we discovered in um
uh in the moon night trailer with the
closed captioning mae calamali's
character she was in um in rami on hulu
she's playing layla last name uh el
fully i'm sorry paulie if i
mispronounced that but there is a famous
marvel laila layla miller from um from
the house of m event she's a mutant who
has the ability to kind of resurrect
dead beings uh in in house of m she
plays a critical role resurrecting
people's uh subconscious states so that
they remember that they are in a uh a
false reality right of the scarlet
witch's making i would be fascinated to
see layla show back up in multiverse of
madness or have some kind of connection
to the mcu house uh house of m event uh
that could just be another layla and
they just honestly like that reminds me
of the time when layla during the house
event event she like restores emma
frost's memory and emma frost is just
pissed she's like are you kidding me
i've been living a fake life this entire
time like oh my god it's one of my
favorite marvel moments it's hilarious
now we don't know much about blade blade
is sometime
in the next two years mahershala ali um
but we did just hear his voice at the
end of eternal so presumably he's
teaming up with dane whitman we're gonna
have a couple different nights you know
um and that could be part of a midnight
suns team up uh ms-13
sort of thing but we
uh this is the corner of the world where
witches could appear
how likely do you think elizabeth olsen
would team up with mahershala you know
like i think because they it's still the
supernatural and we're still dealing
with like a lot of the supernatural
stuff and because blade seems to have a
connection with you know this ebony
blade that dane whitman is you know
almost touched and had himself corrupted
by and like you know in the comics the
ebony blade has links to you know the
the primordial dark times before the big
bang and so with wanda's powers sort of
to me being linked to the that
primordial dark the dark magic of the
universe i think that there is a lot of
opportunity for i think blade might even
want to kill the scarlet witch honestly
like he that actually might be a threat
to for blade to actually tackle because
she is a person and she is stabbable
technically so i would i would say you
know if you can't stab wanda i think
blade's gonna give it a try so i think
blade could be after awana in that
scenario so i think that she could fit
there but yeah what do you think what do
you think i i think of these titles uh
blade would be one of the lesser likely
ones that one shows up and at least of
the titles we've mentioned just because
there's like a whole new corner of the
world and you kind of want that to just
be mahershala's movie at that point um
but we are having a werewolf by night
halloween special it sounds like later
this year and i kind of feel like this
is the opportunity for everybody in the
horror side of the mcu to show up
including like maybe we just have a bit
where we have all of our witches
together we have agatha we have wanda
max moff and then there's just kind of
this comedic routine where wanda is
basically now puppeting agatha but
they're trying to like puppet each other
or something like that see i mentioned
these like live tv specials there's
always like goofy corners like they go
to elvira mistress of the night and
she's doing her puns and they go over to
vincent price i know i'm jumping around
decades here but there's always just
like who's gonna show up now and like
trick or treat like oh i'm gonna say my
stupid jokes and uh you gotta imagine
like the goofy word play that agatha and
wanda were doing in the earlier episodes
of wandavision would fit in perfectly in
this halloween special for sure like so
like so well like i just want to see
agatha in this halloween special
honestly because she would she would
kill her like she's brewing something
like ooh might just have to pour in a
little bit of this and she has her flask
and portions of booze in it you know
what it's all booze we need to have
jared leto cameo and werewolf by night
and then we could just recreate twilight
with the real werewolf and jared leto
and uh wanda maximoff she could be bella
and we could just recreate because
everyone loves twilight a couple years
ago and nobody likes it anymore just
kidding i don't know what i'm saying oh
you have to mt you are walking into
dangerous territory
we how many uh pattinson uh fans do we
now have on this channel from our batman
country you can't be talking robert
pattinson yo he's the guy right now he's
the goat batman to me that dude killed
it in the batman so no disrespect bro no
just because he'll beat my ass he will
be my ass
we can't even claim robert pattinson as
our own if you try to say that like this
is the first time robert patson's really
wowed me you're gonna have
a legion of twilight fans and he replies
saying don't you dare he is our boy
he is ours
and we knew he was great back in 2010
yeah
well uh one more title on the p in the
pipeline that might seem like a weird
choice for wanted to show up in but hear
me out ant-man and the wasp quantomania
already seeming like a pretty crazy
movie if jonathan majors coming back as
kang the conqueror bill murray coming in
playing some insane role but if you
imagine kang is kind of this uh this bad
boy the multiverse don't you think that
he would have crossed paths with wanda
maximoff at some point or have her on
his radar oh yeah for sure i think
there's a there's a huge chance actually
that we could see a kang variant on the
illuminati in multiverse of madness
because sure he's a genius and he is a
multiverse genius in particular so like
it would make sense for him to have a
seat there so like having a wanda cameo
and multi and quantum mania and you know
because we don't necessarily know what
the term quantum mania means but we know
from avengers and game that the quantum
realm has unique like specific ties to
the multiverse so
with wanda having ties to the multiverse
herself i don't think it's out of the
question for wanting to show up in a
quantum mania type title that has to
deal with potentially time travel and
you know multiverse travel and you know
with in again the kang's in this in this
thing so like
i don't think it's super weird for
wanting to be like hey scott
um here's another scott and here's a
different cassie's do you want a little
cassie that you missed out on that of
her childhood here you go here's a
little cassie um but yeah yeah euphoria
cassie here she is she's a lot of drama
[Laughter]
she'll say whatever you want me to be
the bad guy i'll be the bad guy
we're leaving out an important person in
wanda's life in this conversation vision
when is wanda going to reunite with
vision will she ever reunite with vision
we're going to move on to some other
marvel titles that are not currently
confirmed for the mcu pipeline but we
think we'll show up at some point uh and
that wanda could play a very important
role in but first we want to thank some
people who helped us make this episode
thank you to new mood for sponsoring
this episode we're all thinking and
talking more about mental health on both
a personal level and a global level
learning to manage daily stress and
anxious thoughts is something we all
want but many of us don't know where to
even begin well nuum mood is here to
guide you to mental wellness and give
you the tools you need to tackle stress
so you'll feel empowered to take on
whatever life throws at you i'm a huge
believer in nume weight and i'm also
excited to try new mood our favorite
thing about the app is that it is backed
by science there are lessons based in
psychological principles that teach you
about your relationship with stress and
anxiety it takes just 10 minutes a day
and you can do it whenever and wherever
and you can navigate the program at your
own pace and you'll also have the
support of a coach along the way as
experts in behavior change nume has
helped millions of people through their
weight loss program so you know that
they can help you tackle stress as well
worry less and feel happier sign up for
your trial at noom.com
marvel that's n-o-o-m.com
marvel to start your trial and thank you
to helix sleep for sponsoring this
episode mt and i have to be on our
a-game during inside marvel recording
sessions we can't afford to have a bad
night of sleep because of a crappy
mattress that's why we love our helix
mattresses helix sleep is a quiz that
matches your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers i
have a helix mattress and i love it mt's
helix mattress is getting delivered soon
so he'll report back on how much he
loves it in some future episodes the
mattress ships right to your door for
free no need to go to a mattress store
just go to helixsleep.com inside marvel
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you'll get to try it out
for 100 nights risk free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
insidemarvel and we want to thank
bluetooth for sponsoring this episode
we're all pretty confident in our
theories here on inside marvel
confidence can take you pretty far in
life and in the bedroom and that's where
blue chew comes in bluetooth is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable tablets at a fraction of
the cost you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises you sign
up at bluechu.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and it's all
done online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations no
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package so if you
could benefit from some extra confidence
when it's time to perform bluetooth can
help and we've got a special deal for
our listeners try bluetooth free when
you use our promo code marvel at
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluechew.com promo code
marvel to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring the show
all right uh back to wanda maximoff's
future in the mcu what next mnt well our
second question of the day is what
future unannounced mcu titles will wanda
maximoff appear in what do you think
well we've speculated uh for a long time
and this is really the go-to choice for
marvel studios that their next big
crossover event that involves the
avengers should just be secret wars if
you're going to do secret wars if you're
going to make a two-part event secret
words part one and part two this i think
would be the best opportunity for wanda
to reunite with vision because really
secret wars they can kind of resurrect
anyone from any uh timeline in the
universe uh
robert duncan jr tony stark paul bettany
vision and just kind of bring them back
on this battlefront it's almost like a
weirdly hypothetical matchup um i think
this is the best opportunity especially
if they're on opposing sides of the
secret wars like honestly like it's i i
like to think of it as like the super
smash brothers of everything live action
marvel it's like everything like the
playground where everyone just plays and
the crazy things happen um but yeah no
secret wars is definitely the most
likely scenario or wanda will actually
play a magnificent role in as this
reality warping scarlet witch um and
even though like she wasn't like the
main focal figure in the 2015 event like
with you know the future of the mcu and
the way where the mcu is headed i can
definitely see juana maximov and you
know uh even potentially a doctor doom
with like this all-powerful um god-like
power um like
clashing in the in a sort of battle
world secret war scenario but also we
have to also remember that in guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 um on the on the
ships that you know the the guardians
are in to try to destroy ego there is um
a language on there called builder
machine code and the builders are a race
of people that are very much connected
to the whole secret wars conflict so
technically we already do have some type
of secret wars ask tease in the mcu so
we could very well i feel like we're all
already on the road path to this huge
multiversal conflict that uh wanda
maximoff will definitely play a huge
role in that's an interesting point
empty you know what i want to see is uh
like wanda truly in a battle that really
uses her reality warping powers like
imagine thanos with the reality stone
infinity war how he could turn drax to
brock's uh blocks he could turn uh
a mantis into ribbons i want to see
that used but actually you know
consistently in a fight right like what
happens after he's turned into blocks
can he still hop around in the blocks
and come up and like trip people and get
in their face like
let's let's play let's game that out
seriously rather than just treat that as
a one-off gag let's like spend an entire
uh beat of a fight where like mantis is
now in ribbon form like choking people
seriously
i would be down to do that like it would
be kind of graphic but like i would love
if a ribbon mantis was just like choking
people out that'd be hilarious yeah and
like using her ribbons but she still has
her empath powers and she can kind of
like put people in these emotional
trances but now like she can wrap around
multiple people at once because she's a
ribbon like use that exactly and like
they're laughing she's making them laugh
while they die
yeah she just trips so many she
clotheslines a whole row of people
as her ribbon self like i would love to
see a mantis ribbon clothesline um harry
osborne green goblin
just like in spiderman
yes now let's talk about the x-men
obviously the x-men are coming into the
mcu now
how much do we need the scarlet witch to
be part of that x-men lineup like
imagine an x-men lineup that has like
you know you have scott summers you have
storm uh you got knight crawler you got
everybody do you want one want a maximum
off scarlet witch to be there too
as part of the x-men well it all depends
on how the x-men are introduced into the
mcu and like if you know wanda's chaos
magic ends up being the catalyst for the
mcu x-men then absolutely if she's like
the mother of the x-men then i would
love for her to just have a presence
maybe not be in professor xavier's
school but like you know because like
historically in the marvel comics she's
like uh this pariah witch that like no
one really likes for the most part like
she's wasn't she part of like the
brotherhood like didn't she start as
part of the mutant brotherhood before
like becoming just a regular mutant
hanging around in the mcu like she's
part of like magneto's crew i think she
was hanging around with magneto's crew
for a bit um i have to brush up my
knowledge on that for a bit um but yeah
i know i could definitely see her
being like an ushering in the mutants in
the mcu in in a definite scenario where
in in multiverse of madness where she
says more mutants please and mutants are
now in the mcu but like i don't i don't
know if she would fit in xavier school
but she could definitely play a role in
an x-men film for sure yeah i i think at
that point it's kind of like with blade
like when you're introducing a lot of
new characters like i don't need wanda
max mob part of that story right like
there's so many other the x-men there's
just so many freaking x-men and i'd
rather see i'd rather you spend that
part of the production budget on just a
new character just cast a new character
i want to see all the like all the weird
x-men powers in the school like there's
so many weird powers like just show me
that like i've seen enough cyclops i'm
no more
jeez right
right whatever money you'd give
elizabeth olsen for that just pay
whoever you're paying storm double like
i want different storm type powers not
just the lightning please i want she can
do other stuff like let's see other
stuff monsoons exactly
dust dust bowls
famines
just pure famines everywhere just really
overly humid bedrooms oh my god that's
the worst one
[Laughter]
well let's let's end on this question of
are we gonna see scarlet witch solo
films like we already had a scarlet
witch solo series well i don't have a
solo series it's kind of a duo series of
wanda and vision and wanavision uh but
are we gonna see a like a solo series
like just a scarlet witch title a
trilogy even my god i would really hope
so because like you know
given with these rumors of this contract
being extended
i think that kevin feige might be
thinking scarlet witch solo films
especially after the success in the
popularity of wanda vision people cannot
stop talking about the one division era
i can't stop thinking about the one
division era it was just a great time
and so like people love wanda max about
people just love the way that she uses
her powers and how her powers are linked
to her emotions so like i think that
scarlet witch solo films would be very
successful if marvel studios were to
pursue that so i definitely see can see
that in their future for sure what do
you think yeah you just have to get
really creative with uh who what
villains you're pairing her against what
crises she's facing because i think
there's only so many like epic major
crossover multiversal crises that you
can have wanda involved in in the
broader mcu where she's like
you know paired up with with doctor
strange or vision um or agatha like we
saw that one division we've seen a
multiverse of madness and potentially
we'll see it in secret wars so like what
else beyond that like what else beyond
house of m is a good scarlet witch story
and i think if she turns inward into her
witchcraft right so like
exploring her witchcraft exploring her
reality bending powers that we saw at
the beginning of wanovision where she's
like creating different sitcom homages i
think that would be the aspects to her
character that gets explored in the
future and maybe she uh comes across
other past witches who are able to
manipulate her or teach her more or be
mentors to her um
uh you know we can get even darker in
her relationship with vision something
with her sons you know like there are
there's like an interesting like witch
chronicles
direction for scarlet witch in the
future you know like to see the history
of her witchcraft and uh maybe her
attempts to
lead uh a new
legacy of witchcraft in the mcu uh in
the way that like imagine the story of
star wars the story of the jedi and
their creepy witchcraft dogma uh i'm
just
replaced luke skywalker for wanda
maximoff and yeah we had nine star wars
movies uh in the skywalker nunology uh
so potentially there could be something
there with with wanda maximoff as well
but and for sure like in like all of us
like the history of sokovia i feel like
there must be some type of
like mystical part of the water because
like they seem like a very spiritual
type of um like country so like i just
feel like having a solo series explore
like what juanamatic wanda maximoff is
lineages was and like who her
grandmother was and like because like
maybe her grandmother had ties to the
scarlet witch prophecy as well much like
you know um agatha's mother was this
super powerful witch in salem so i mean
i think we're going to learn about
wounded gore mountain i think that's
where multiverse of madness is going i
wouldn't be surprised if like we learned
more about magda her mother
uh and and pietro's origin i mean we
there was was it oleg and arena maximoff
were the names of the parents that we
saw in the flashback of one division we
didn't see where those kids were born
though
and what the exact nature of their
births were
so yeah there is more story to be told
there absolutely but we did know from uh
i believe it was the wakandaphiles book
right the one with all shuri's notes in
it and they said specifically sokovia
was chosen by hydra because there's
something in the dna of the people there
that made them more um you know
useful test subjects for their mind
stone experiments so it could be a clue
for something more
for sure i feel like sokovia is going to
be a major part of the mcu mythos moving
forward it's very important well we'll
leave it there for this episode of
inside marvel let us know what future
title you want to see wanda maximoff
show up in the mcu is there a title that
we didn't mention that you think would
be a good movie or disney plus series
don't forget to check out our many great
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
and uh you can follow me at eavos follow
mt at mastertainment subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcasts
thank you for watching and we'll see you
next week bye
you